We were really
trying to increase
the efficiency by which a
report is generated from what
surgical pathologists do on a
day to day basis, which is look
at tissue sections under a
microscope and render diagnoses
after examination and studies.
We're four students at MIT--
MBA, EMBA, and then
two PhD students.
And we've been
working on a project
to rethink the
process of sign out
in the pathology
department, and facilitate
the transition to a paperless
diagnosis entry system.
We've been thinking
about overall workflows--
kind of who's doing
what during the day,
to the granularity of how the
monitor is set up in the booth.
We did a lot of observation from
the transcriptionists at 6:30
in the morning, to
the slide technicians
and the gross description
at 7 o'clock at night.
And really seeing that
full workflow of what's
happening every day.
Do you feel like overall
typing versus handwriting
when you're doing
slide previewing,
do you think it's
better or worse?
I think it's actually
much easier to type it.
By having the H Lab
come in and work
with us having a fresh set
of eyes from the outside,
because we're biased.
We're in the system,
we're biased.
It's great to have
that set of eyes
because they will say, well,
yes, if we change one thing,
it could change
four other things.
So we're trying to
anticipate what might happen.
I talked with one of the
members of the staff.
She told me this
experience would be better
for the residents if
we had two screens.
And I was looking
at the office, I
mean, there's some
obviously that you clearly--
the way they're set up, you can
not put easily a second screen.
We are proposing a change.
And we're proposing a
change that will impact all
the doctors', basically,
day to day life.
And there are some people
who've been working here
for 30 years in their own way.
And they have already
figured out the best,
kind of the most
efficient way for them.
And we want to bring
technology to make
their life a lot more efficient,
but suggesting this change
and expecting this change
to be accepted by doctors
who are used to their own way
of doing, is very challenging.
One of the themes that we've
really seen from our interview
so far is there's a fear of
the documentation burden being
shifted to
physicians, and that's
something that we need to--
Change is, of course,
difficult, and people
have a lot of anxiety
about some of the changes
we're talking about in terms
of paperless implementation.
We're putting out a
survey to the staff--
how many minutes a day do you
spend with just IT issues?
We can implement all of this.
And if we don't have
the infrastructure
to support what we're trying
to do, then it's meaningless.
We have observed-- and
we'll be very honest
here with the frustrations
and skepticism
around paperless
initiatives-- when
we ask different
doctors like, oh, how
do you go about
asking for new devices
when the systems
are very antiquated?
Almost all the doctors had
very different responses.
And that was very
surprising to me
because, in fact,
in any enterprise,
IT support systems should be--
everyone should have a single
kind of email or hotline
that they can reach out to.
One of the frustrations that
a lot of pathologists have,
including myself at times, is
when you go to partner's IT,
you get a ticket,
you wait, they come,
and they rebuild your computer.
That's their solution.
If we are really pushing that
we move to a paperless system,
this IT support system can
not provide a good foundation
to allow our doctors to be
successful in this system.
The student team built
a simulation model
to then show the leadership
here the different changes
in what the effects
would be and where
they should start from an
implementation standpoint.
In the simulation model,
the way this works is we
have cases arriving
according to a process that's
based on the data.
You go from accessioning
to gross examination,
then the case splits for slide
processing and collation,
and continues through.
As it gets to certain
steps, and there
are no resources available,
it ends up waiting in a queue.
There are different ways you can
choose to allocate resources.
Maybe changing the
shift schedule,
changing the way that you
staff the slide technician
at certain times
versus transcriptionist
or how long can you
let the QA review
go before it becomes
a bottleneck?
Types of questions
like that, we think,
could be answered
with this model.
We knew where we
wanted to get, we just
didn't know how to get there.
They pointed out the
challenges, the things
we need to do to help
overcome those obstacles,
and then gave us phases in
which to implement this program.
Using these tools, they
now have the data in order
to affect change within
their own organization.
So it gives them credibility
amongst their peers,
and with their leadership, in
order to improve the system.
The final product
is really amazing.
It's something that you
can do something with.
There's a set of
practical solutions.
There's a proposed timeline
for implementation.
The project itself
actually taught you
how to interact with
the organization.
Get your hands dirty and see
how things are working on a day
to day basis.
At the end of the
class, you definitely
realize the system is as
complex, and probably more
complex, than you thought
it was when you went in,
but you also see
that there really
are so many opportunities
to improve the system.
And there are so many
people from industry,
from academic settings, who
are really committed to making
those change.
So there's no shortage
of ideas, and there's
no shortage to
buy-in, and it's just
a matter of getting it done.
I learned many things
from my colleagues.
I learned from my teachers,
I learned from my hosts,
I learned from everybody.
And I hope that others have also
learned something from myself.
So this exchange of knowledge,
exchange of experience
is a journey that we really see
ourselves growing over time,
as people, as professionals,
as human beings.